We have three answers--we can quickly rule out these because these should be less likely
from a loaded coin that's disproportionately heads since they each have more tails than heads.
We can also say that if four heads in a row is sufficient evidence
that we have a loaded coin 10 and 20 heads should be two.
So let's just evaluate this for the four heads' case.
So the probability of having four heads in a row from a loaded coin is going to be 0.6561.
Whereas the probability for a fair coin is 0.0625 but remember
this just gives us the probability of flips given fair and given loaded.
What is we have to multiply each of these by the probability of fair
and the probability of loaded and so those are.
So we can see here the probability of having a loaded coin times the probability of the flips
given the loaded coin is 0.06561 and the probability of having
the same flips with a fair coin times its probability is 0.05625.
Together they are equal to P of flips.
So only one of these divided by that can be greater than 50% so it's going to be the bigger one
that's going to be P of loaded, and if P of loaded given flips is greater than 0.5
then P of fair must be less.
So this is true which means this is true and this is true.